[Musique]
bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro de page
consacrée au deuxième tour des
législatives et à leurs conséquences à
ses conséquences plutôt en français il
ya beaucoup de choses à dire donc je
vous présente les invités armel le bras
chopard bonjour bonjour la pauvre
émérite de sciences politiques et elle a
fait rater vous êtes beaucoup intéressé
aux femmes en politique votre dernier
ouvrage s'appelle femmes et république
et on parle maintenant d'elisabeth
bornes beaucoup de boue maintenant déjà
de sa compétence ou de sa capacité à
être premier ministre et peut-être que
le fait qu'elle soit une femme vous nous
direz si ça si ça joue un rôle ou pas
d'être ce qu'elles plus important c'est
que les femmes le nombre de femmes a
régressé ce qu'on note passer dans
l'assemblée de la zone b pourtant
absolument 35 de troyes ça c'est un
événement pour moi
véronique jérôme bouchot bonjour patrice
est de conférences de sciences de
gestion université de paris saclay et
vous êtes l'alco catrice avec d'autres
universités
du responsable du site élections scop et
je dois dire que je suis
ébahi à chaque fois alors en janvier
vous aviez prévu à la
décimale près le score des
présidentielles et là il ya un mois un
peu plus d'un mois voulait envoyer les
prévisions des
d'élections scop pour législatives et
alors que tous les sondages nous disait
il y aura une majorité absolue pour la
majorité présidentielle
pas ou du g dans notre dans votre étude
y aura peu près 240 députés
dans la majorité présidentielle et le lr
la droite jouera le rôle d'un parti
charnière c'était c'était un moment où
les sondages disaient tout à fait autre
chose je précise que élections scop ne
fonctionne pas avec les sondages c'est
une scientifique qui tient compte des
votes précédents notamment et puis de
l'état d'esprit des
juste pour préciser au ce qu'on avait
fait et ce qu'on a donné c'était sur la
métropole donc sur les 5 539 siège de
métropole et là on a des résultats qui
sont très précis la seule difficulté
c'est qu'on a finalement comme un effet
de vases communicants ce que ce que l'on
avait prévu pour nuxe où on a des
données
219 voix à nu pts et la gauche entière à
cette année de plus à gauche extrême
gauche ils ont eu 137 sur la métropole
on s'est trompé de 80 de voix on a
surestimé de 82 et on en même temps
sous-estimé le rn 2 82 donc voilà cet
effet de vases communicants cette
porosité qui équipe on essaye de
s'expliquer quand on le moment nous
aviez voit l'arrivée prévue qu'il n'y
aurait qu'une majorité relative majorité
relative pour emmanuel macron parce
qu'on avait donné deux cent trente et
une voix pour l'ensemble solal total de
131 sièges par geoffrey meyer bonjour ça
va bien vous êtes avocat au barreau de
versailles vont maintenant aussi un
secrétaire de la conférence finale je
suis désormais on s'entasse coupe des
jeunes il pousse
absolument j'ai été contraint moi aussi
de rendre mon de rendre mon mandat voilà
vous il verse à la jolie bonjour vous
êtes éditeur et alors là vous apportez
métastases métastases de des scans
ya deux meurtres
arrive c'est l'usure meurtre ans et
transgenres dans marianne un système à
lyon un artiste 30 gens qui se fait
assassiner en plein concert un imam
plutôt modéré qui se fait exécuter avec
sa famille dans un parking ça c'est le
côté vraiment un peu sociale et actuel
et puis un côté romans noirs denses que
ça décrit la réalité des sociétés
françaises et notamment du nord de la
france et puis il ya deux deux tueurs en
série qui sont traqués en plus par par
les trois les trois flics et voyous
commandant
la capitaine et la femme comme vous
voilà la femme du capitaine commune et
voilà et il ya aussi la
dgsi qui a déjà et ceux qui s'impliquent
là dedans parce que ça arrange beaucoup
de monde
le chaos organisé dans certaines églises
luxe faire annoncer ça s'appelle donc
métastases ps gagnent et 7 aux éditions
la joie ni évidemment
on va on va aborder des élections et et
on va commencer par ce constat moi je je
pense que tout le monde perd mais vous
allez me dire si vous êtes d'accord
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que tout le monde perd
emmanuel macron père parce qu'il n'a pas
de majorité absolue jean luc mélenchon
père puisque il nous disait je vais être
premier ministre il ne sera pas pour le
ministre et en plus le score de la
gauche et pas très élevé c'est à 29%
c'est le score le plus bas de la gauche
on pourrait dire que marine le pen n'a
pas gagné mais en tout cas elle est
toujours la tête d'un parti qu'un parti
d'opposition et non pas partie du
gouvernement et la droite perd quand
même la moitié de ses députés
sur cette analyse à mal vous êtes à peu
près d'accord ou pas je suis d'accord
peut-être un peu moins sûr ben voilà sur
le pen parce que c'était pas l'élection
de prédilection pour elle elle s'était
peu intéressés on le sait au départ
souhaitait avoir juste un groupe oui
c'est une
c'est une bonne d'une bonne surprise
pour elle donc moi je considère pas que
c'est perdre va tout dépend comment on
se situe par rapport à gagné et perdu
bon ce qui est sûr c'est que pour le
reste je suis d'accord avec votre
analyse et y compris pour
pour la nuque produits oui parce que oui
c'est cela la gauche 29% c'est pas
énorme mais si on regarde l'assemblée
alors si on rajoute et puisque l'année
il dit que les mercredis sont à droite
donc si on rajoute des macros distler et
le et le rn ça fait ça fait une france
très adroite au fond mais ce qu'est ce
qu'ils quittent à celle face qu'ils qui
correspond aux études qui ont été faites
des haut-rhinois la droitisation delà de
la société dans son ensemble l'ironie
bien quelques choses un peu différemment
j'ai l'impression que personne ne gagne
en même temps tout le monde gagne pas
tout le monde croit avoir gagné quand on
écoute un peu les raisonner discours on
a cette impression de ce qu'elles disent
mot voilà ses discours politiques
stratégies bien évidemment mais ça peut
produire ça peut produire un souci entre
guillemets c'est que finalement on a pas
on n'a pas cette de cette franche cette
france assemblée nationale avec cette
franche majorité et non pas y avoir un
souci et pour un majeur et la majorité
présidentielle qui va consister à la
chercher quand même 44 44 députés pour
avoir la possibilité de faire passer
avec le plein des voix une vraie
majorité faire passer des lois il y aura
peut-être pas nécessairement besoin de
cette majorité forte pour faire passer
toutes les lois mais il y aura quand
même un souci c'est que quand on vient
d'être réélu quand le président la
république viendrait d'être réélu les
miettes confirmé dans cette réélection
par une assemblée qui va le soutenir et
là le problème va se poser sur le plan
des réformes je dirais les moins
impopulaire et là sur les réformes les
moins impopulaire il y aura finalement
un arbitrage soit il les fait quand même
et il va devoir à nouveau triangle de
trianguler sur sa droite il va devoir
aller chercher à droite les voix dont il
a besoin pour faire des réformes alors
la retraite à 65 ans forcément il n'y a
que la droite pour les plus impopulaires
alors là les plus impopulaires et les
jeunes populaires c'est le plus en plus
impopulaire les plus impopulaires qui
seront d'autant plus difficiles à faire
oui c'est en début de mandat qu'il n'a
pas d'état de grâce parce que
généralement en début de mandat ont fait
passer des réformes qui ce plus
difficile et plus difficile on a un état
de grâce on est populaire on peut
choisir peut-être à presque aux comment
ça va se passer maintenant mais sur le
constat des élections jean charles
devrais je trouve curieux que vous
puissiez dire que le front national
n'est pas gagnée en le rassemblement
national n'est pas gagnant puisque quand
même passé de 7 à 89 députés si ses
parents si ça ne s'apparente pas une
victoire qu'est ce que c'est qu'une
victoire là ce qu'on revient en revanche
je sais ce que disent qu'il est presque
une victoire contre leur gré
ça peut pas dire qu'on nie que
j'apprécie ses détracteurs mais en mieux
et
en revanche c'est une montre qui peuvent
rentrer à l'assemblée sans scrutin
proportionnel au bout et puis il ya une
vraie défaite fait une véritable défaite
c'est celle de jean luc mélenchon parce
que on peut se peut s'enorgueillir
vaguement d'un score quand même pas
terrible de nuxe ou de nu baisse parce
qu'il faut dire enfin la france
insoumise et quand même c'est pas énorme
ses 71 députés je crois enfin julien ccc
moins que fonde le rassemblement
national c'est un véritable échec pour
le type piper royan disant je vais être
premier ministre
c'est c'est un échec total qu
est ce qu on a on est loin des forces de
pouvoir être premier ministre avec 71
députés
sur provimi tout le monde savait que
c'était c'était une fadaise coiffante
nullement facile à la presse en avait
peut-être chez un peu oui voilà
geoffrey veiller très rapidement moi je
suis je suis dacc en fait en litige suis
d'accord et pas d'accord avec vous
concernant le qui gagne et qui perd
alors concernant ceux qui ont perdu
alors il faut toujours à mon avis mais
peut-être aurez-vous un avis différent
du mien c'est qu'il faut toujours mettre
en perspective cette élection
législative avec cette élection
présidentielle puisque chronologiquement
elles se suivent immédiatement même si
effectivement elle sont
fonctionnellement différentes malgré
tout lorsqu'on voit les scores qu'ont pu
faire et l'air par exemple à la
présidentielle on aurait pu dire que le
désastre était encourue aux législatives
or or oui alors je suis d'accord avec
vous sur le fait qu'ils ont perdu des
députés par rapport à ce qu'ils avaient
en 2010 est même voix roulerait ils
peuvent jouer un rôle ils ont quand même
maintenu 74 alors que leurs partis fait
moins de 5% la présidentielle et en ça
je suis pas tout à fait certain qu'il
faille caractérisé le score 2 à l'air
comme une défaite aux législatives
à mon avis ce point une victoire
historique bourdin 26 ans prend ainsi
reprendre l'histoire un peu longue alors
évidemment par rapport à 2010 at mais
c'était quand même le parti avec le ps
un qui a gouverné l'alaska le but je
suis parfaitement date et là ils ont
quand même je crois qu'il fait d'accord
avec vous mais je pense qu'il faut quand
même relativiser ce qu'on peut appeler
l'échec de l air plus que ils auront
quand même malgré tout un rôle à jouer à
challans a cessé à l'assemblée nationale
est effectivement par contre sur la
nuque est ce là je rejoins parfaitement
votre avis est clairement à mon avis une
défaite de ce parti qui pourtant avait
permis un rassemblement en fin de la
gauche au moins sûr dans un but
électoral et lorsqu'on voit comment
mélenchon avait été portée à la
présidentielle on aurait pu envisager on
aurait pu imaginer que le score soit
différent ou moins qu'il soit un petit
peu meilleur que ce qu'il n'est parce
qu'on voit les prédictions alité cette
assemblée nationale correspond assez au
premier tour de la présidentielle ces
résultats des législatives
ça correspond mais en même temps là où
je suis pas tout à fait d'accord tel que
il faut
comparez ce qui est comparable donc
c'est plus logique de comparer pour l
air avec les députés qu'ils avaient
avant et donc tu oui dans une maison
perdue si il y aussi un je dirais un
choix qui était sous contrainte sous la
contrainte des duels et quand on regarde
oui alors il ya quelques études qui ont
été faites rapidement je crois que c'est
mathieu gaillard qui a fait ça ce matin
dans les duels lr rassemblement national
lr a gagné à 94% lannux contre le
rassemblement national n'a gagné que 52%
lannux contre ensemble à gagner à 64% et
ensemble contre le rassemblement
national a gagné 50% de ces duels sont
gagnés 50 50 et donc la voilà on voit
bien
évolué et c'est très intéressant cette
voie bien ce qu'on appelait le plafond
de verre là il est il est peut-être en
train de s'élever encore plus tous
qu'elle sait pas si des clubs doit pas s
élèvent des choses des choses bien il ya
quand même toujours on en parlait la
semaine dernière mais
25 millions de français qui ont pas voté
70% des jeunes qui vont pas voter il ya
quand même derrière tout ça une sorte de
de crise démocratique en maintenant
oui oui il ya une crise démocratique
dans la mesure où les élections ne sont
plus courus comme elle était avant ne
sont plus un événement sauf les médias
qui en font un événement au moment de la
la campagne en particulier pour le
deuxième tour et il y a aussi d'autres
alternatives pour la démocratie qui sont
mises en avant il ya le mouvement
associatif
est assez puissant actuellement c'est à
dire qu'on va s'impliquer dans tel ou
tel domaine
particulier par le domaine général que
couvre les élections mais
la lap la participation aux élections ne
semble plus lui quelque chose
ces marques de la citoyenneté en quelque
sorte oui parce que plus de plus
d'abstentionnistes que de votre
panneau plus de quoi précipiter vers
l'est vers les urnes il n'y a pas
véritablement de débats
il n'ya pas qu'est ce qu'on pouvait le
seul petit le seul petit point de
divergence entre les uns et les autres
un peu petit mais c'est la retraite à
150 pas mais c'est vrai que quand on a
19 ans 20 ans est ce que c'est vraiment
quelque chose de très fédérateur la
retraite à 65 ans je ne pense pas sinon
après il ya les élucubrations économique
de l'ain qui sont à peu près aussi
stupide que les élucubrations économique
de marine le pen enfin je veux dire donc
mélenchon marine économiquement ça n'a
pas d'intérêt je comprends que ça
séduisent pas voilà donc il n'y a pas
tellement de raison de se déplacer comme
un fou a pas vraiment aimé la politique
et se dire bah oui faut faire attention
ce serait bien ou pas que le président
et la majorité absolue etc mais ça on
rentre déjà dans des calculs et dans des
noues pour des gens qui sans qu'ils
s'intéressent vraiment la police sinon
c'est vrai que mélenchon a essayé de
mobiliser des jeunes à lille
pour des benêts
il essayait de les mobiliser ça marchait
dans certains dans certains quartiers on
parlera peut-être des yvelines attrape
il ya quand même un
forte participation par rapport aux
habitudes
ça peut marcher partout
c'est sans doute aussi que les sujets
qui produit peuvent préoccuper les
jeunes et les moins de 35 ans ont été ça
rejoint un petit peu ce que vous disiez
insuffisamment abordée dans le cadre de
la campagne présidentielle est également
dans le cas des législatives mais c'est
pas plus grave que ça c'est pas plus
il ya un problème avec les communautés
d'existence je crois que ça fait déjà
pratiquement trois décennies prépuce ses
relais et que le la nécessité d'aller
voter le cern a nécessité morale parce
que finalement c'est un engagement que
l'on que l'on a sans même se poser la
question c'est un devoir enfin l'or
s'est pas inscrit c'est pas y'a pas de
sanction en france en tout cas et je
pense que cet aspect quand même qui fait
que pour moi la vérité du vote vient de
celui qui s'engage qui va de son plein
gré voter celui qu'on va un peu à qui on
va imposer le vote celui à qui on va
dire c'est le vote où la sanction tu vas
voter si tu tapes stien tu est
sanctionné je pense que ça ne produira
rien de mon et puis concernant les
jeunes ya juste un petit point que je
voulais ajouter c'est que il ne voyait
peut-être pas toutes les conséquences de
leur choix parce que finalement pour la
plupart ils ne sont pas encore engagés
dans la vie active donc les conséquences
économiques des choix politiques oui
c'est loin ils ne sont pas habilités
pour l'instant et ce sont leurs parents
qui
éclaire un peu ce que vous dites les
jeunes eux des courants plus ou blood
éditeurs dans un iut à rambouillet donc
pas très loin d'ici dans certaines
classes que j'ai j'ai interrogé il ya
trois semaines une étudiante qui ne
savait pas qui était le premier ministre
de la france donc si vous dire qu'elle
va lancer une dévasté castex ou comme
annoncé
elisabeth bourguinat but bref
on se sent pas non mais non c'est dire
eh oui un lien des peugeot peu
d'éléments qui ont soufflé un lien mais
j'entendais quelques-uns que dire oui
c'est une femme j'aime et donc comment
est-ce qu'on peut passer de quelqu'un
qui ne sait pas qui est le premier ni de
la france accueille la beauté c'est
parce que je dirige des différends sur
et céramiste c'est tant mieux si vous
n'allez pas voter mais cgc
ça me pose un vrai problème quand même
cette désaffection c'est un problème
d'éducation j'apprends le mal vous avez
cité des causes qui sont des causes pour
ces élections est
un mouvement
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus anciens et
en ce qui concerne les jeunes il ya
quand même un point où mélenchon a
touché les jeunes c'est sûr parcours sup
d'après des enquêtes ou des
interviews mini trottoir
les jeunes ont quand même accroché là
dessus c'est peut-être une des raisons
peut-être pas à trappes mais pour
lesquelles certains jeunes se sont
portés à toutes les tailles les jeux ont
voté ont voté massivement sage et
l'encens et conduire
la cause l'attention alors pas
nécessairement chez les jeunes mais de
l'abstention globale elle peut être
institutionnels aussi dans le sens où on
fait déplacer des électeurs alors bien
sûr que c'est un bien sûr que c'est un
droit et un devoir mais toujours est il
qu'on les fait déplacer quatre fois deux
fois pour le premier tour 20 pour
l'élection présidentielle est quasi
concomitamment deux fois pour l'élection
législative or à l'époque où nous avions
le septennat présidentiel il est éveillé
le thé banking energy initiative il y
avait effectivement une forme de
respiration qui se faisait et alors
peut-être peut-être que le
le taux d'abstention serait différent
s'il n'y avait pas de suivi entre
l'élection présidentielle élection du
stati v6 on était encore sous cet ancien
mode deux septennats ou peut-être ami
trop rigide non mais c'est vrai que
c'est vrai qu'il
ya un projet de mettre les élections
présidentielle et législatives le même
jour mais c'est vrai c'est vrai que il
ya aussi le ferons d'en parler il y
avait beaucoup de duels donc il ya des
des champions qui sont engagées au
premier tour il ya un candidat qui n'est
peut-être pas non plus d'aller au
village et choisir des entre deux
candidats pour lesquels il n'avait pas
voté au premier tour à tour pouvoir
jouer aussi c'est l'agent fait les
lecteurs fait enfin l'électeur peut être
un peu stratège parce que finalement et
swahili va ils sont pas tous stratège de
l'électron verrai quand même que
globalement ils ont ils ont usé d'une
certaine stratégie pour qu'on en arrive
à ce point mais pas de majorité claire
et que finalement on a une partie qui
sont allés voter c'est ce que je disais
la semaine dernière je crois c'est que
l'offre aussi est en cause l'offre
politique le fait de proposer un
candidat de l'union sachant que l'union
ne s'est pas faite autour d'un pivot
autour d'un pivot central je parle de
lannux par exemple l'union s'est fait
autour de
don forcément le lecteur ps peut-être du
mal à se reconnaître dans le candidat de
la nuque ce qu'on va lui donner donc
soit il est allé voter en se disant je
suis fidèle à mon camp je vais voter
soit il s'est abstenu en disant
débrouillez vous finalement ce n'est
plus mon problème donc on peut avoir cet
aspect aussi qui peut expliquer des
choses actuellement est-ce que vous dire
que du coup la france a perdu et
secourisme en raison de mon père parce
que c'est vrai qu'on est dans une
période un peu compliquée
extérieurement nikon uniquement et que
voilà c'est peut-être probablement un
effet pervers de la campagne de
mélenchon c'est à dire que finalement
mélenchon et la nuque ce qui voulait
tirer la france vers la gauche voire
l'extrême gauche ils vont toucher la
france vers la droite parce que c'est un
combat sais pas c'est pas chez nuxe qui
va trouver les alliés donc il ya plutôt
les trouver chez les républicains donc
ils poussent le gouvernement allait tout
vers sa droite serré qui les attire si
vous étiez à droite veut lui vole t pour
la nuque ça vous ici le lr sera le parti
gerb hier cette rixe et les lecteurs
on va on va passer banon met donc on a
les résultats qu est-ce que qu'est ce
qui peut se passer maintenant comment
gouverner c'est de ce dossier me tartine
cette émission
[Musique]
je vous propose d'écouter une députée
qui est eric ministre de l'outre-mer
c'est seuil elles broutent pie v le soir
de sa réélection dans la 5e
circonscription des yvelines ça va être
difficile parce que notre assemblée et a
été bâti pour fonctionner selon une
règle majoritaire en appui du programme
d'un gouvernement veut nous ne sommes
pas dans un régime parlementaire et donc
il va falloir
trouver des majorités aller chercher des
consensus c'est forcément plus compliqué
mais c'est ce que les français
souhaitent que nous fassions donc il
faut que nous soyons maintenant à leur
écoute ils ont souhaité une assemblée
très variés mais à nous maintenant de
nous montrer à la hauteur des soins
qu'ils ont exprimée dans les urnes
aujourd'hui
voilà c'est le résume assez bien là la
réalité c'est vrai qu on parlait
beaucoup il ya peut-être aussi une
victime collatérale de ceux de ce
scrutin c'est le scrutin majoritaire à
deux tours puisque vous dites jusqu'à
présent il est injuste mais au moins il
produit permet d'une majorité stable là
on voit qu'il est toujours à juste mais
ne permet pas de mains détestable donc
autant elle est la proportionnelle non
oui oui autant pas y aller puisque toute
façon la proportionnelle
mais c'est comme c'était une demande
assez forte parce que tous les gens qui
disent aujourd'hui ah oui il va falloir
négocier afin qu'ils étaient favorables
la
proportionnelle il aurait fallu de toute
façon des dossiers on serait dans une
situation qui serait sans doute encore
plus difficile que celle là mais le
point de vue c'était de celui de la
représentativité de la guerre bien
représenté sur le plan est ce parce que
le gig les horribles
relation de ce qui se passait ensuite
sur les alliances est une question qui
se posait jamais ce qu elle simplement
il faut mieux représenter les français
et c'est vrai que là on a une petite
proportionnelle qui ne dit pas son nom
et qui
vous est tout à fait raison c'est une
question de représentation par contre se
pose aussi la question de d'être élu
pour gouverner s'agissant de la
présidentielle et d'être élu pour être
aux affaires s'agissant des législatives
donc là il ya quand même il ya quand
même double vision la vision d'une
stratégie politique et c'est un peu ce
que certains ses écrits politiques
disent est ce que l'on veut gagner les
élections et faire un programme pour
gagner les élections et uniquement
gagner les élections où est-ce qu'on
veut gagner des élections pour appliquer
son programme et là le programme
disparaît dans ces danses et jeux
d'alliances le programme n'est plus haut
n'est plus mis en avant la prise en
charge on n'était pas pas apparus et ont
peut-être là le luxe devrait vous n'avez
pas beaucoup de visibilité sur le
programme des zones et des autres ont
seulement compute
cloud
oc voilà l'absence de programmer deux
campagnes notamment de la part du
président qui ne s'est pas trop engagé
qui n'a pas vraiment mouillé la chemise
en l'occurrence qui lui a fait dire
finalement et qui l'obligé à aller sur
le terrain de ce qui reste finalement
son territoire c'est à dire le régalien
est il sain peut comporter j'allais
presque utiliser une image un peu fort
mais comme s'ils étaient en cohabitation
c'est à dire qu'il a conservé le
régalien il a parlé sur le tarmac il a
parlé de l'étranger depuis l'étranger
des élections françaises qui est quand
même un peu là aussi un peu une entorse
à ce qui se fait habituellement et en
même temps il a montré une forme de
faiblesse en ne s'engageant pas et ça
c'était peut-être eu erreur de stratégie
de sport nécessité surtout il a pensé
que comme il avait gagné les
présidentielles il n'arrêtait pas de
répéter de toute façon ça c'est toujours
un livre ça s'est toujours produit j'en
étais presque absolu alors ne pas
mouiller sa chemise c'est aussi éviter
les erreurs sa mémoire c'est bon
marché quand y'a eu l'épaule le premier
tour des élections législatives c'est la
douche froide mais c'est pas il n'est
pas sensible à ce genre de chose il n'a
pas encore bien compris mais un tout
petit peu quand même sur le tarmac las
il fait au lieu de d'annoncer des
réformes positives
il agite le chiffon rouge en particulier
vis-à-vis de lannux d'amer de dire
qui même la position de l'homme
providentiel déjà le tarmac l'avion
derrière et c'est l'homme providentiel
c'est à dire que ce qu'il demandait
c'est ayez foi en moi ayez foi c'est
votre programme le ne votez pas pour les
autres c'est au choix qui a marché
pendant longtemps et qui a fait le front
républicain notamment fin ça marche
beaucoup moins bien aujourd'hui quoi on
voit bien la clé avec les votes pour
leur n 1 et des jeunes qui a coûté
chamboule-tout serre que les gens
proches de maquereau ou vraiment
étiqueté pro macron proche de macron
quand même pris de grosses claques que
ce soit qu'à scanner offert en sélection
quand même c'est pas c'est pas
économiquement qui ont été dégagés je
veux dire ferrand dans le
dans sa bretagne faisait bien le job
enfin je veux dire il n'y a pas de
personnes pouvaient lui dire oui
économique on zappe pas plus qu'eux mais
simplement c'était le président de
l'assemblée nationale le proche est
proche de deux schémas cronk à sa mère
c'est pareil les bons chemins de la
ministre aussi tous ceux qui ont payé
leur est souvent enseignants bourguignon
aussi quitté très bien et de jusqu'ici
qui est bien mise de la santé qui est
battu c'est vrai qu'il ya des symboles
quoi après cette fois un peu pas et
c'est pareil pour tous et la démocratie
mais c'est souvent plus ça a peu de voix
ça c'est pas non plus des raz-de-marée
il fallait
600 watts différence c'est ce que disait
c'est pas nous un pourcent près il y
avait la majorité absolue c'est pas
c'est pas non plus
mais ça va être serré que ça se voit
alors donc on a une configuration avec
trois grands blocs le bloc de la
majorité présidentielle qui à
245 sièges
et puis deux blocs un peu extrémiste le
rn avec 89 on pourrait dire attention
pendant la nuit passe on pourrait dire
peut-être et les filles est défi qu'il
ya soixante douze députés qu'ils soient
un peu les extrêmes après les
écologistes et socialistes plusieurs on
verra est-ce que ce qu'ils peuvent voter
ce qu'ils peuvent s'abstenir dans un
certain nombre de votes c'est possible
et puis 61 députés pendant l'ère est un
peu plus si on ajoute des zi et les
divers droite soit 114 équipe qui peut
jouer en effet le rôle de parti fermiers
ce qui est quand même très amusant enfin
amusant ou inquiétant jamais celle de
l'attitude de mélenchon qui dès lundi
disait on va faire qu'un seul groupe est
en gros je vois qu'une seule terre la
semaine et puis vous allez tous me fais
de la politique mais politiquement fin
du produit c'est pas idiot aura duré
moins de 24 heures c'est à dire que les
écolos les socialistes et les
communistes 10 milliards de questions on
veut nos groupes et il n'y aura jamais
de groupe unique l'époque pour des
raisons financières il est intéressant
mais dans les années socialistes ont
bouffé leur chapeau si en plus vous leur
dites y'a pus d'il ya plus de gens
tandis que la provision n'allait pas
être acceptées mais politiquement c'est
pas totalement idiot de dire on est un
groupe de gauche qui est le plus fort de
l'assemblée c'était ça peut se défendre
politiquement qu'en juin non
mélenchon non c'est tout à fait dans le
sens ligne dans ces lignes mais leur
choix y va où tout est oui quand il a
annoncé qu' il fallait me l'élire
premier ministre oui tout le monde était
stupéfait et finalement ce samedi là il
a forcé la main à ces trois autres
partenaires des trois autres groupes
partenaires et peut-être qu'ils
pensaient leur encore en les prenant de
vitesse lorsque leur forcer la main et à
ce moment là s'il y avait eu que la
nuque c'est effectivement c'était pour
lui aussi c'est impossible s'il n'y
avait eu que la nuque ce qu'est ce qu'il
y a majoritaire c'est la france a
soumises et les autres parties est
complètement absorbé seulement aimer
c'est ce qu'il essaye de faire ce que je
sais ce qu'il est c'est là je crois que
s'est terminée cette autre sur dix ont
ces
gens compris vin
il faudrait faire des juniors électorale
d'union politique et les autres ne
veulent que communion électoral qui leur
a permis d'avoir débuté au beausset et
de l'argent l'argent est évidemment de
l'argent oui non mais pour le ps même si
c'est inespéré
il revient
donc je disais que c'était de toute
façon pas soluble dans un
dans une assemblée dans laquelle ils
n'étaient pas majoritaires ça rejoint
parfaitement ce que vous dit j'ai c'est
que ça aurait pu fonctionner si jamais
il avait une majorité qu'il aurait
permis d'entrer au gouvernement mais là
étant donné que ville sont minoritaires
la nuque ne pouvait pas rester soluble
dans une opposition alors gérer une
question parce qu'on entend partout
voilà c'est un échec terrible pour
manuel macron athena est ce que c'est si
grave que ça ne pas avoir une majorité
absolue parce que il n'ya pas quand on
n'a pas une majorité absolue ça ne pas
le dire que tout le monde votre contre
vous il y en a qui s'abstiennent il y en
a qui en principe pas au vote et ça peut
ça peut garantir comme des majorités
alors le problème c'est effectivement
par le fait d'avoir manqué la majorité
absolue on parle de majorité relative
mais le recul lundi elle est fortement
il faut se souvenir en 88 avec michel
rocard kekel dernière exemple qu'on peut
la dernière référence qu'on peut avoir
avec 14 voix de différence seulement
quatorze voix et michel rocard et vous
avez à votre collègue guy carcassonne
carcassonne accueille beaucoup qui a
beaucoup oeuvré pour il allait voir les
connaissait tout le monde et les uns et
les autres et ils pouvaient faire
modifier l'attitude en se tournant
tantôt vers l'est communiste à l'époque
était important donc comme le centriste
voulez ou les centristes sans parler du
49-3 t laquelle
19 x et concours est un moins utilisé
aujourd'hui
par session et pour le budget et pour la
sécurité je crois aussi comme si on fait
une une session extraordinaire mais
toute façon ça nous amène à pas
l'utiliser trois ou quatre fois mais
vous pensez donc ça va être compliqué ou
pas pour le pour le gouvernement ah oui
je pense que ça va être très compliqué
très compliqué
compliqué ça va être compliqué parce que
l'assemblée va être houleuse oui c'était
déjà au point de vue des débats ce que
ça va être vraiment ils sont tous soumis
et 80 la rsa sera fait plus il a semblé
et moins houleux dans la rue alors donc
c'est sale c'est intéressant parce que
là la rue avait plus difficiles à
mobiliser puisque on franchira aux 1/2
pas avoir donné leurs voix aux aux de
l'avoir donné
parti majoritaire
c'est le rôle derrière du parlement
les conflits se joue là dans la ccin
effectivement sur le plan démocratique
ce n'est pas inintéressant on retrouve
un réel débat à l'assemblée elle
semblait d'autant que lorsqu'on regarde
sa composition excusez ma patrie je vous
ai compris lorsqu'on regarde sa
composition on se dit que malgré tout en
fonction des sujets en fonction des
thèmes qui seront débattus il ya la
possibilité pour ensemble d'aller
chercher soi des soutiens sur sa droite
avec l air soit éventuellement je vous
dis en fonction des thèmes qui seront
abordés sur sa gauche avec qui a quand
même 22 député divers gauche qui sont
éventuellement mobilisable par rapport
aux par rapport aux lois qui seront et
qui seront évoqués et éventuellement
même au sein de la nuque mais ce qui qui
n'existe pas mais dont on a
besoin de regarder il ya 22 députés
socialistes on peut tout à fait
envisager que eux aussi
rallye la majorité si jamais si jamais
la nécessité et que et dire pardon
voulez pas vous interromps mais c'est
vrai que l'on parle par exemple de
motion de censure et jean luc mélenchon
a déjà déposé une motion de censure pour
le 5 juillet sans savoir qui sera
premier ministre
qu'est-ce qu'il dit réserver mais le
temps que pour aucune motion de censure
sont votés il faudrait qu'elle soit
qu'elle soit établie dans les mêmes
termes et par la nuque et pas le rn et
on n'y pas de jour où la rn l univers on
se met d'accord survolions de censure je
compte les poules auront des dents
sellal avantage qui n'est pas une
culture de compromis chennouf oui parce
que comme ça on est sûr que est reine et
l'extrême gauche ne font pas ça l'idée
donc effectivement
ni les l air qui pourrait avoir envie de
faire tomber le gouvernement nie
le rassemblement national
9 rbds ont signé une charte avec qui est
lancée par mélenchon mélenchon c'est
toujours ça même tactique toujours le
coup d'avancé 17 juillet
démocratiquement ceci serait bien aussi
que mélenchon réalise qui n'a pas été
élu président la république et que là il
ne s'étant pas présenté n'est pas non
plus députés donc là il se conduit comme
s'il était député dit je vais déposer
une motion de censure sera supprimé
ce n'était pas à lui de dire
s'il faudrait il rappeler avoir par
moment les redites anneaux je passe je
ne suis pas sûr que il soit de l'intérêt
de l air de faire tourner mac rond parce
que finalement il n'y a pas de figure
justement voilà les oppositions ont soit
des figures usées et marine le pen ne
retournera pas la présidentielle
mélenchon non plus et l air pour
l'instant je cherche un candidat dans
près de là il n'y a pas de chef le chef
s'en va et d'en haut c'est à dire un
chef il ya trop de chaque soir s'il ya
des problèmes on voit bien que l air est
coupée on est trois presque mais bien
admirer ciotti gré volontiers un peu
vers le rn
jacob qui n'y a pas de pas de pas de
compromission avec mâcon et puis on voit
seul maire de saint-etienne incertain
copé qui disent euro pourraient
personnes d'accord de gouvernement donc
on voit bien qu'il ya eu match elles
font en effet le problème est là c'est
si on voit dans le long terme il n'y a
pas de chef et donc l'intérêt du
l'intérêt du parti c'est quand même de
trouver un chef emblématique qui se pose
en tant que président du parti n'ose y
présidentiable pour la prochaine
échéance qui marque déjà finalement des
points et et là j'ai l'impression qu'il
ya une usure une usure des hommes au
sens premier du terme fait bon et une
usure au sens cost of falling mesure de
pouvoir et jacob bien pesées et l'usure
du pouvoir des balades de tous les
responsables des partis se poserait même
la question si vous voulez aller au bout
de la réflexion est-ce que emmanuel
macron n'est pas dans une forme d'usure
du pouvoir j'ai lu ici et là des
éléments qui commence à dire c'est la
fin du deuxième mandat qui à peine
engagé c'est ce matin sur je ne sais
plus quel en serait on sait que le
deuxième balle est toujours
il est certain aussi radio on pose la
question ils ont posé la question aux
éditeurs est-ce que macro est entre
guillemets cramer et à 64% ils ont
répondu oui il ya quand même un signal
qui est envoyée
visiblement personne n'a voulu se cramer
avec lui parce que non mais le maire du
havre il a quand même fait une campagne
législative d'une discrétion qui force
le respect j'adore finit pas oui on a
vraiment l'impression que c'était tout
le monde est un acquis abc lanouette on
va attendre que le boulet passent et
plus on verra s'ils reviendront quand
même non comment le signal venait d'en
haut s'il manuellement pour lui-même qui
est parfaitement fin à ce point là je
pense qu'il a été dépassé par c'est la
première vie nice dont plus
simplement ce que disait je ferai pas ce
que vous disiez on peut trouver des
majorités successives il ya aussi la
possibilité c'est ce que c'est ça qu'on
appelle jean françois copé d'un pacte de
gouvernement c'est dire que là on
négocie au diwan a ouvert cinq réformes
ces réformes on est d'accord là dessus
on y va ensemble et là il peut y avoir
une majorité absolue ça peut être oui
sauf que l air n'en veut pas enfin
christian jacob a été très peu
il semblerait que les 40 que les cadres
effectivement un peu usé ne soit pas
pour un accord de
pacte de gouvernement sauf copé valérie
pécresse
pencherait peut-être pour 7,7 cette
solution oui mais on va dans cette
enquête prouve que
les électeurs pas de l air en revanche
serait assez pour un pacte de
gouvernement mais macron lui taille par
les délais cramé il est usé c'est je
crois qu'il ya un véritable problème de
sa personnalité je crois qu'il n'a pu
dit et il me propose rien
de nouveau et on voit bien la
procrastination
actuelle darda a nommé une première
ministre tout en ayant annoncé davance
une femme mystérieuse qui
a tardé c'est pas vraiment le signe
d'usure pour moi il est plus oui mais le
problème ce qui complique lorsqu'on dit
que ce n'était que ces trois fermes et
problème c'est qu'ils continuent là on
est avec à
il a déjà passé à contre sens tant il
semble quand les gens n'aiment pas les
enterrer trop vite et
qu'il est très connu aussi parce qu'il
sait quelle forme de rejet il peut aussi
susciter chez les acteurs il s'agit je
pense qu'il l'a vu quand même mais il a
quand même eu un quinquennat
particulièrement apocalyptique on a
entre eux ce que fut la crise des gels
et jaune puis derrière la crise
sanitaire il avait quand même il avait
quand même une société à la fin qui
était quand même vraiment est sur les
charbons ardents le sur un fil jeux jeux
il a mon avis je pense qu'il n'est pas
dupe du fait qu' il peut passer
l'association forme de rejet et donc qui
se met en retrait il gère les relations
internationales puisque nécessité
faisant loi il faut les gérer en ce
moment parce qu'en plus ça lui permet de
regagner une forme de légitimité
politique mais à mon avis sur tous les
sujets intérieur il se met un petit peu
en retrait parce qu'il sait que c'est
jamais il s'expose trop ça peut être
néfaste comme tous les deuxièmes mandat
je veux dire chirac a été assez en
retrait pendant son deuxième mandat et
c'est plutôt consacré à la politique
extérieure
est ce que fait vingt ans que feu
mitterrand pour des raisons aussi de
cohabitation aussi mais enfin il était
très à cheval sur ses prérogatives en
matière de politique extérieure donc
donc c'est un peu ce que pour les
préserver leur deuxième mandat c'est
vrai que c'est toujours compliqué pour
les deuxième mandat
nouveauté aussi parce que c'est la
première fois dans l'histoire de la vème
république version quinquennat qu'un
président est réélu
mais bien sûr bien sûr mais à chaque
fois que les présents étaient réélus ils
sortaient pas habitations tel
colonisation donc finalement il
réamorcer un nouveau soutien est là pour
le coup c'est pas le cas donc c'est
avons aussi jeune et c'était très
intéressant dire parce que les gens
vassalisés
et l'imac rond mais on ne veut pas que
les une majorité à l'assemblée nationale
s'était senti très mal car oui c'est
absolument clair clément expo en dehors
de démocratie
un mot sur elisabeth bornes ajustements
2e première ministre de la france pas
une situation facile on parle déjà du
fait qu'elle ne serait pas la bonne
personne pour conduire cette politique
le fait qu'elle soit une femme ça joue
sajou peut-être dans le fait d'être
compliqué de la renvoyer d'ailleurs
c'est parce que c'est pas un vrai cadeau
qu'on a fait aux femmes non les abords
premier point donc là la personne de
toute façon on a dit qu'elle était
transparente elle a absolument pas mener
la campagne des législatives elle s'est
occupée de sa circonscription est là il
veut élu avec 52 % ce qui paraît énorme
dans un fief hyper macro nice tu es la
une voir
monocorde vous l'avez entendu le soir
des législatives avec cette oratrice et
tous à trois heures avec le avec macron
pour une nous sortir des platitudes une
langue de bois nous dire qu'il y avait
un risque oui bon il ya un risque
voilà le l'action la question alors
qu'elle est complètement
tant attendu le soir même marine le pen
mélenchon et elisabeth bornes on débat
là il n'y a pas photo entre les trois
ans quand il y en a deux qui sont dans
le truc troisième c'est à son tuteur et
ce presque il faut être heureux dit
aussi l est pas politique mais ça veut
dire quoi de politique
une présence politique est en fait il
n'a pas la communication avec vous et
moi et bien qu'en ce mois là c'est la
faute je pense que le souhaite mais je
pense qu'elle est faux elle fait danser
et je pense qu'elle a une histoire
personnelle qui explique cette seule
cette rigueur qu'elle a donc acquis qui
sortent de tous les côtés dans ce qui
reste c'est qu'elle respire mais en même
temps je pense qu'elle veut garder une
distance et qu'elle veut garder une
distance pour établir son autorité parce
qu'on disait quand même qu'elle a une
forme d'autorité pour une femme
c'est naturel je devrais pas dire ça
mais ça c'est naturel de toujours avoir
l'impression d'être obligé d'en faire un
peu plus que si on est un homme pour
prouver et pour être crédible étant dans
cette position de première ministre mme
nadhir une femme premier ministre après
tout la fonction n'a pas de sexe me
semble-t-il et de l'homme doit honorer
la fonction la femme ou l'homme doit
demeurer la fonction c'est pas la
fonction qui honore c'est l'homme ou la
femme qui doit respecter et honorer la
fonction et là je pense qu'elle veut
tellement honoré qu'elle s'oublie et
qu'elle oublie même qu'elle a un côté
humain qui devrait passer parce que
généralement c'est là aussi qu'on voit
les politiques et je pense que si on se
souvient aussi d'edith cresson politique
générale présentation de petites général
edith cresson dans l'assemblée enfin
c'est ça parlera certainement pas aux
jeunes qu'ils osent parler du scrutin et
il ya quand même eu un à une espèce de
malaise et ça a continué et là je ne
sais pas comment on peut imaginer les
choses se passaient pour vaincre on peut
imaginer que le disque général d abord
je l'aï une grosse interrogation parce
que nous fait regretter castex
ces actions n'ont pas les mains
complètement libres pour nommer le ou la
futur premier bruit un ministre
ce qui va peut-être se passer c'est que
bon elisabeth bornes va disparaître
et il y aura peut-être un homme après
voilà ce sera
la femme la seconde femme
restait encore moins longtemps et
c'était des créations qui était acheteur
mais ces tests au sein de ses
déplacements la remplacer par son
premier choix et l2
qui est plus à droite quelle étape dans
libération qui est plus à droite alors
que c'est vrai
aussi évidemment qui sait qu'une
politique alors sur le goût et message
des électeurs sont peut-être plus à
l'est vers la droite que bien que mal à
gauche donc remplacé vous avez tout à
fait raison une femme par une femme
sincère enlèverait tout le côté bah oui
c'est une femme qui est viré non sprint
femme qui est viré c'est un premier
ministre qui est plus ou moins bon on
passe on passe aux yvelines peut-être
c'est intéressant comme ce qui s'est
passé ici est là c'est le troisième
parti dans les yvelines
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il ya douze circonscriptions sur les
deux circonscriptions dix députés de la
majorité
présidentielle
d'où deux modem et le reste le reste
étant des ensembles enfin des
renaissances plus tôt et puis deux
nouveaux députés elle fit dans la nuque
mais ce moment dans la 8ème et dans leur
11e circonscription la 8e
circonscription ses ventes en gros un
élan deuxième ces trappes voilà attrapé
long cours en outre c'est ça
alors je propose des parfums de c'est
vrai que les les les députés lauriers
les nouveaux comme charles rodwell ou ou
karl olive dans la première 12e qui sont
très largement réélu ils sont élus par
don puisque c'est des nouveaux
dans l'ensemble des recettes des
élections assez facile hein on vous dira
sa volée sur les futures élections
ah non ça c'est la nuque ce qu'il a dit
oui non non je prends de l'élection des
députés sortants métro disent tu sors
tôt en nouveaux ils sont tous serez lui
où il faudra plus de 60% des voix
souffre peut-être là qu'elle liait le
bon vive et qu'il s'est un petit peu
moins varie le bec 65 c'est quand même
nom vient de m'envoyer 65 pratiquement
et donc ses succès dans c'est énorme
c'est peut-être nadia est alors qu'ils
acquièrent
d'abyei et d'anciennes miss de la ville
qui avait changé de circonscription qui
est élu avec 56 % c c'est comme c'est
une trêve
c'est venu
nous fait du tort
à ce pc des femmes en politique qui
parle donc
on vous écoute à noter que parmi ceux
qui ne l'ont été paquet qui ne pourra
pas revenir gouvernement trois femmes
oui absolument les trois battues sont
toutes femmes ces hommes bourguignon
mon chemin et
la mère sont pas démissionnaires pour
l'instant elles peuvent pas démissionner
puisque président a refusé la démission
de l'esab et de bornes et donc j'ai
appris mais le support sous votre
contrôle à tous les trois mois je n'ai
pas grand chose ou si précisément que en
fait à un gouvernement démissionnaire ne
pourrait pas ne pourrait rien décrété
donc en fait c'est pour ça qu'il a
refusé la démission et que donc tous les
ministres est en place pour l'instant
mais celles ci permettent décrété mais
ça permet de de décréter des choses
sinon
les trois ministres qui devait partir
pour l'instant ne sont pas partis et
sont alors qu'approche de partir mais de
toute façon je pense que rahin certain
délai entre d'abord il aboyait des
voyages à l'extérieur qui vous dans les
semaines qui viennent pour le président
de la république et je pense qu'ils
auront un certain délai entre le fait
que les images bande présente sa
démission qu'elle soit acceptée et qu'un
nouveau gouvernement soit soir soit
renault mais je pense qu'il prend son
temps comme il l'a fait jusqu'à présent
c'est une stratégie bain c'est vrai
qu'il vaut mieux partir d'autant qu'il a
pris quant à lui pas le feu au lac
se fait par romain 10 mois de septembre
la télé sauf
c'est en effet les deux 2 candidats de
la gauche qui ont été et bidon alors il
faudra compter que la 11e
circonscription est une circonscription
qui bouge souvent été l'intervention de
benoît hamon quand la gauche était au
pouvoir s'était elle était passée à
droite après la passe et aux lois vent à
lesterps droite elle est venue à mon
après les passer à l'ère m avec nadir il
est revenu à droite après une élection
partielle à philippe benassaya et là
elle revient à gauche c'est vrai qu'elle
elle bouge beaucoup à cette session à
mal le poteau par le 11e oui peut-être
que démocratiquement elle bouge beaucoup
aussi c'est beau
c'est
démographiquement
les jeunes sont à 100 majoritaire
donc il ya eu beaucoup d'abstention mais
on peut penser qu'il ya quand même
quelques jeunes qui ont été votées ce
qui expliquerait tout même ce
basculement est donc de série à il ya en
tout une bonne mobilisation à travers
nantes voilà et et philippe une vraie
campagne une vraie campagne devrait
comme la mobilisation bat je vous
propose de voir un sujet de nicolas
baudens dry justement sur les bases les
deux nouveaux députés de gauche
la gauche avait percé au premier tour
des élections législatives la gauche
confirme son retour dans les yvelines la
nouvelle union populaire écologique et
social aura deux députés yvelinois
l'assemblée nationale suite aux
élections législatives d'abord dans la
8e circonscription benjamins lucas
s'impose largement je fais campagne
depuis des semaines auprès des habitants
et des habitants pour convaincre pour
mobiliser parce que j'ai entendu des
souffrances parce que j'ai entendu aussi
des envies des attentes des aspirations
qui correspondait je crois à ce que je
portais à ce que nous portions dans
cette campagne sur le pouvoir d'achat
sur la justice sociale notamment sur le
respect et la dignité pour chacune et
pour chacun donc ça ne me surprend pas
c'est l'ampleur du résultat qui me
surprend en revanche parce qu'il est
très large et plus large que ce que je
croyais pas ce qui a fait la différence
c'est qu'on a fait campagne
d'arrache-pied qu'on est allé voir des
milliers de gens qu'on a frappé à des
milliers de portes que qu'on a échangé
qu'on a écouté ça a été une campagne de
dialogue une campagne d'idées en tête
lors du premier tour le candidat de la
nouvelle récolte 5000 voix
supplémentaires au second tour sur
l'ensemble de la circonscription à
mantes la jolie le dépasse les 60% avec
une abstention plus faible qu'au premier
tour résultat pour moi même quinze mille
sept cent cinquante neuf voix
[Applaudissements]
même phénomène dans la 11e
circonscription où il ya martin et
devient le député de ce territoire il
devance la candidate de la majorité
présidentielle
aurélie pia senza 217 voix seulement
notre réservoir de voix c'était les
abstentionnistes voilà il avait rien
d'automatique et de et de mécanique pour
pouvoir faire plus de 50% des voix il a
fallu retourner sur le terrain et à
réussir à convaincre à la fois nos
compositions mais ça c'était pas le plus
difficile le smic à 1500 euros la
retraite à 60 ans le blocage des prix
c'est des mesures qui sont majoritaires
ultra majoritaire dans le pays ce qui a
été le plus difficile c'est de
convaincre qu'il était possible de
gagner bien entendu est arrivé en tête à
trappes qui est la première ville de la
circonscription donc c'est ce qui a fait
l'écart entre
a priori sur sur les résultats attrape
le candidat de l'ani ps récolte 78% des
suffrages avec une participation plus
importante par rapport au premier tour
sur l'ensemble de la 11e circonscription
où il ya martin et gagne un peu moins de
5000 voix par rapport au premier scrutin
c'est intéressant parce que plus grosse
participation amant théâtre
et une augmentation de la participation
au deuxième tour alors que au niveau
national 2 % de moins de participation
ce qui fait qu'on arrive véritablement
un record d'abstention jamais jamais
connu mais ce qui prouve bien que
c'est très difficile de mesurer
l'abstention et il semble bien que y
compris au niveau national il ya eu des
transferts des personnes qui n'ont pas
voté au premier tour des législatives
qui se sont mobilisés pour le deuxième
tour et bien c'est pas le même et se
sont pas les mêmes c'est très difficile
de mesurer et donc là il semble qu'il y
ait eu un sursaut aude pour le deuxième
tour en voyant que peut-être la nuque
j'avais des chances de gagner et c'est
les mobilisations oui les initiations et
vous le savez utiliser je ne sais pas
dire mais les chefs des l'hellénisation
effets de symétrie dans pardon dans la
mobilisation une forme d'asymétrie c'est
plus ceux qui voulaient revendiquer et
sortir les sortants et il est plus
facile de les mobiliser ici visiblement
que de mobiliser pour soutenir et
confirmé d'ailleurs je ne peux pas dire
de bêtises mais les deux sortants
c'était c-26 recours question était tenu
par lr 1
c'était génial et la 8e et la cia alors
11e il me semble pas qu'il est appelé à
voter contre le candidat de lannux mais
enfin ce que je peux me tromper mais
semble pas qu'il appelle d'ailleurs
c'est ce qu'est ce qui est quand même
intéressant vous je voyais sourire vous
jean-charles aussi quand on entendait le
le nouveau député donc de gauche qui
demandent quand on va prendre avec la
retraite à 60 ans le spica 14 100 euros
et sutil vous quelle est la troisième
mesure et le blocage des prix
sont concernés par le financement de ces
mesures c'est encore plus plus efficace
parce que finalement il suffit de
proposer et puis les promesses
n'engagent que ceux qui les écoutent si
on peut parler peu vulgairement et d'un
autre côté c'est chirac
[Rires]
mais forcément les jeunes sont sans le
fameux jeunes peuvent être entre autres
les jeunes peuvent être sensibles à ces
arguments c'est ce qui fait la
différence entre le politicien et
politiques le politicien vend son
programme il se fait élire le politique
lui pense un peu plus loin n'a pas cette
myopie il pense aux conséquences des
annonces qu'il a faites et comment
financer parce que là on est quand même
certains disent certains macro
économistes disent on est à l'os j'aime
pas l'image mais c'est un peu la réalité
on est alors sur beaucoup de choses et
sur les dépenses et sur les recettes et
sur la sur la dette on prévoit 3000
milliards d'euros de dette publique à
passer ou pas si lointaine échéance donc
comment faire si la croissance ne
revient pas et la croissance on est déjà
réduit les prévisions de croissance de
4% est passé à 2,4 prévisions on n'y est
pas encore donc si on n'a pas la
croissance si on n'a pas la formule
magique si on n'a plus les robinets
ouverts par la banque centrale
européenne si on a pu toutes ses sources
de financement qui était facile bien
facile et qui facilité les choses
comment va-t-on faire c'est la grosse
question c'est politiquement ça veut
dire que c'est toujours plus facile
d'être candidat d'opposition que gauche
de gouvernement qu'on peut on veut dire
un peu ce qu'on veut pas de crise en
tout cas
c'est vrai que le discours modéré est
toujours plus compliqué à faire passer
non oui mais pour être élu et quand on
est candidat ouais faut séduire et
comment est ce qu ont séduit bon séduit
par des promesses par un récit on en a
parlé la semaine dernière et forcément
il faut que le récit est une issue
heureuse donc il faut que
les prix seraient bloqués que smic soit
1500 euros par mois et que la retraite
soit à 60 ans
bah haute tension ce qui va être
intéressant c'est qu'on va être il ya un
retour de la politique en tout cas m de
toute façon intéressante au
j'ai dit tant mieux et va sûrement voir
ne serait-ce que sur la réforme des
retraites ça peut être pas 65 mais
peut-être que voilà ça sera un soutien
de
63me qui peut être que positive sous
contrôle c'est vrai que jusqu'à présent
le pays était relativement difficile à
gouverner parce que les candidats aux
présidentielles faisait 25 27 pour son
premier tour et quand ils se mettent à
appliquer leur programme ils ont à peu
près 60 70 63 qui sont contre là il va
falloir trouver des alliances ça va
peut-être un peu
favorisés finalement peut-être plus les
réformes que ça ne pourrait débloquer
si on est optimiste la preuve on vient
d'imaginer aussi une recomposition
politique parce que le les républicains
vont se vont se diviser
tout va dépendre de qui prend la tête
des républicains mais on peut aussi
imaginer qu'il y ait un jour une idée de
faire un grand parti de droite alliant
une droite extrême et une droite voilà
et puis tué l'autre partie halliche et
mâcon donc c'est ça peut cette
recomposition elle est aidée il faut la
prendre en compte cette possibilité de
composition merci beaucoup merci tous
les cas merci à mme elle devrait choquer
je rappelle votre livre ces femmes et
république enfin c'est un livre
collectif il est très très très bon
livre historique et politique merci jean
charles genis rappelle donc métastases
sont là je la vis
merci vous vous offrez milliards bonne
pleansri merci vous partez et puis j'en
commande là évidemment le site et
lectures scor
perd 2 0 merci beaucoup
[Musique]